&gt;&gt; Our slope is negative 3, or negative 3 divided by 1. It terms of direction,
we know we need to travel down 3 units and then right 1 unit. From our y
intercept we travel down 3 units and to the right 1 unit. We wind up at 1,
negative 4. So this point is certainly on our graph. Once we have two points, we
can connect our line and draw it in. We can see we have some other points on our
graph, like negative 1, 2 and negative 2, 5. But these aren't any of these other
points, so they don't work. If you also plugged in these values for x and y into
our equation, you would find that you'd get a statement that wasn't true. So
these points aren't on the line because they don't satifsy our equation. If
you're still having some trouble with slope, remember you can always refer back
to the directions. You start at the point, and move down 3 and right 1. Drawing
your arrows to help you out.